all right joining me now is missouri
senator josh hawley uh senator we're
watching these results uh come in very
close at this moment in pennsylvania
your reaction to the angle specifically
putting the petty squabbles of the
primaries behind us and moving forward
to win in november
i would just say laura that i think
you've got it right and to all of those
in the republican party when it comes to
the squabbles who have tried to gin up
some kind of a war between
the trump or populist wing of the party
and the establishment republicans it's
time to admit defeat on that the voters
in the republican primaries have made
very clear what they want they want an
agenda that is focused on their needs
there is no war in the republican party
the republican voters have made it very
clear and now it's time to unite behind
that populist agenda and drive it to
victory in november
well meanwhile we do have a bit of a
twist with mitch mcconnell who has come
out and has used the i word and it's not
ingram but it is isolationist senator
hawley when he was describing where i
guess you and and others obviously
people like myself and uh a tucker
perhaps at fox
they just don't they don't want to send
billions and billions to ukraine so is
the isolationist
label
fair or a good idea
i would say that what i describe myself
as laura and i think we're the american
people are is we're nationalists and my
concern with the ukraine aid package 40
billion dollars to ukraine is that it's
not national security it's
nation-building i mean this is right
back to the failed policy in afghanistan
and iraq where we are literally funding
the ukrainian government this aid
package would write a check for nine
billion dollars directly to the
ukrainian government that's in addition
to all of the other money so listen i'm
not for nation building i'm for putting
the national security of the american
people first that's nationalism that's
the best tradition of the republican
party and it's time we got back to it
and it seems like that really is the
message from these primaries to at least
so far that people are focused home
they're at they're focused on their
families gas prices food prices the
border crime
want the best for ukraine but we're out
of dough i mean i said we're we're broke
we're woke and we're becoming a joke i
mean it rhymes but it also sadly happens
to be true
well the thing about the ukraine a
package when you're talking about 40
billion is you could build the border
wall twice over laura with that money
and it's time that we got serious about
these pressing priorities and by the way
we've got other pressing priorities
abroad as well like china for instance
which is a massive national security
threat so the time has come to be
realistic here and to put the national
security interest to the american people
first and that means securing our
borders that means taking care of the
crime wave here in this country and it
means getting tough on china well the
trump tariffs on china
are a really big deal that would that
took a lot of work on his part bob
lighthizer the us trade rep who endorsed
dave mccormick i might add along with uh
mike pompeo in the pennsylvania race i
think lighthizer knows a lot about who's
the real populist perhaps in this race
but it's too close we don't know what's
going to happen but on on this front on
china
all the people who want to focus on
ukraine where's the focus on the biggest
threat to the united states which is the
ccp
you never hear them talk about that as
much
that's absolutely right and this is not
the time can i just say to go soft on
china and repeal those china tariffs
which is what the biden administration
is doing you've got the president out
there saying oh yeah we're looking at
rolling back these tariffs unfortunately
some republicans want to go along with
that don't do it this is not a disaster
we need to protect our industry the
total disaster the total wrong move we
should be screwing down the restrictions
on china we should be getting tougher on
china we should be building up our own
industry and bringing those jobs back to
this country i mean i know the baby
formula thing it doesn't really have
anything to do with china but it just
brings the point home hammers at home
we have to make essential
elements to our daily lives for our
daily lives here
we have to make more stuff here
and you know i know the free traders
like oh it's free trade free trade but
we're seeing what's happening as a
result we're seeing shortages cars
everything that we can't get get here
now parts i mean for guards we we gotta
that playing field has to be
leveled
and one of the best ways to bring down
inflation laura is to bring back those
supply chains so that we're not
dependent on overseas supply chains in
particular we're not dependent on china
why in the world would we want our
critical goods our critical
manufacturing uh our critical drugs and
other devices to be made in china it's
absolutely insane and so this is the
kind of nationalist foreign policy we
need something that's going to focus on
building up the united states that's
going to get tough on our enemies and
our opponent opponents and is going to
put national security of the american
people first peace through strength we
have to have our strength renewed here
in the united states senator thank you
so much hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else